hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm jonald Humphrey we're gonna learn
about some go see us today considering
the sensational box office run that
Godzilla king of the monsters is having
right now hop reward to your requests
comes from Andrew Hayes has a wonderful
YouTube channel go check it out he loves
wrestling he loves movies love shows he
loves us top 10 epic Godzilla moments I
recently just watched Godzilla Shin it
oh I will share my opinion on that after
this video and is that a good movie I
liked it a lot more than other brand
time for the real king to shine welcome
to watchmojo.com or Becca's voices
before we begin we publish new content
every day so be sure to subscribe to our
channel and ring the bell do that for us
to fight about their first two yes
for this list we're looking at our
favorite moments from the Godzilla
series called from every era of the
franchise with over 30 films the
Godzilla series has some standout I
guess
also you should probably be there
spoiler alert number 10 the
thousand-year dragon
godzilla mothra and king ghidorah giant
monsters all-out attack so here's the
thing about Bhakra across her many film
appearances she has a tendency towards
dying usually by sacrificing herself for
the greater good
the elaborately titled mm rod entry in
the Godzilla series features one of her
more dramatic moments of self-sacrifice
and one with a surprising beneficiary
guardzilla did it the normally evil King
Ghidorah is on the side of good opera
and Barragan fight off an evil Godzilla
after falling in the epic final showdown
Mothra uses the last of her energy to
power up Ghidorah giving the so-called
thousand-year dragon a fighting chance
when you take one for the team Mothra
number nine Godzilla kick Godzilla
versus mega Wan let's be honest here a
lot of the classic Godzilla movies are
pretty darn silly example than this one
which sees Godzilla teaming up with a
robot named Jet Jaguar during the duos
that's my new nickname Godzilla employs
some questionable fighting moves not the
least of which is this flying dropkick
try to explain the physics behind this
move it's probably why would you go with
it and enjoy the moment for how absurd
it is
like this point Godzilla was basically a
giant green superhero and while his
antics may have been extraordinarily
silly they were also a lot of fun number
eight super mecha godzilla combining
giant robots has been a part of Japanese
pop culture almost as long as Godzilla
so it's no surprise that someone combine
the two afterall Godzilla has his own
giant robot nemesis in the form of mecha
godzilla and what do you do when that's
not enough go that's what after mecha
godzilla has invested by his scaly
counterpart it combines with a flying
vehicle called Garuda to assume a more
powerful form
well we're gonna build them to look
exactly like gods yeah that's gonna be
my record this mechanical doppelganger
obtains isn't nothing to scoff at firing
results
number seven Godzilla's first appearance
Godzilla
we call him oh yeah
say what you will about the 2014
Godzilla but this moment was pretty
great
unlike Roland Emmerich's poor attempt in
98 Gareth Edwards gritty reboot plays it
very coy with the titular monster
showing Godzilla and the enemy monsters
as sparingly as possible to maximize the
impact when they are on screen
this approach definitely works best for
Godzilla's debut which is about as epic
as one could possibly hope for
with Godzilla emerging from the sea like
a living natural disaster and eventually
coming face-to-face with the Muto to
deliver an earth-shattering
[Music]
kind of like the leader in the final
showdown
this was one moment that was definitely
worth waiting for yeah butter in his
mouth Ghidorah
the three-headed monster up until this
point in the Godzilla franchise the
titular monster had been very firmly on
the villain side of things but as bad as
Godzilla was the three-headed space
dragon known as King Ghidorah was worse
at least three times worse to be
specific this is why I adore his
appearance and subsequent attack on
earth project ugh I wanna know between
beating astral monster and Godzilla
Mothra and Rodan well it may look kind
of goofy by today's standards this
sequence was really a massive sea change
for the Godzilla franchise and by
extension kaiju films as a whole number
five a grand entrance terror of mecha
godzilla by the mid 70's the Godzilla
franchise had become a shadow of its
former self failing to bring in the kind
of box office results the studio wanted
in an effort to revitalize the series
producers brought back director Ichiro
Honda who directed many of the early
films the results didn't quite work the
way they wanted and the film
underperformed enough to put the series
into temporary retirement oh man still
the film has more artistic flair than
many of its contemporaries a clear sign
of Hondas hand on the wheel
a great example of this is Godzilla's
entrance to the film complete with
dramatic backlighting and the classic
that's great
[Music]
number four Battle Royale
destroy all monsters
Oh battlin Ghidorah the three-headed
monster may have been the first time
Godzilla and friends battled together
against the space dragon but it wasn't
at the last a kaiju battle royale to end
them all this entry in the franchise
brought together an unprecedented number
of monster combatants it was basically
the Avengers endgame of its time
culminated in a massive showdown between
Vidura and almost every kaiju that had
been established at that point in many
ways it's the end of the 60s and 70s era
Godzilla movies and monster action
Godzilla vs. Zillah Godzilla final Wars
like we said earlier the 1998 Godzilla
reboot by director Roland Emmerich was
not great to put it very much good-o
studios which produce the original films
in Japan not too happy either as they
began building up for the real Godzilla
to get his fiery revenge on his American
counterpart in the franchise's 2004
entry Godzilla finally faces off against
the intentionally poorly rendered CGI
monster now does the villa
and also kill submitted five seconds
destroyed
yeah that's all it took to bring down
this fish loving oversized iguana
considering missiles killed him in the
98 film
it's no wonder Zola didn't stand a
chance against the game number two
Godzilla reborn whoa Godzilla vs.
destoroyah his entry in the series
Godzilla's final curtain call with the
iconic monster dying when his internal
nuclear reactor because yes Godzilla has
one and melt it down
but while Godzilla technically got a
dramatic and moving death scene you just
can't keep a good monster down the
Heisei series of films of which this
movie is apart heavily featured an
infant Godzilla as well who was there to
witness the demise of his own Oh
[Music]
absorbing the massive discharge of
energy the baby Godzilla quickly grew to
full size leading to this insanely
dramatic final shot that capped off the
Heisei series on a serious high note
before we unveil our number 1 cent man
there are some monstrous honorable
mentions
[Music]
[Applause]
at least rent that constantly again
[Music]
number one Godzilla attacks Tokyo Zilla
before he was a guardian of the earth
Godzilla was first envisioned as a
turrible for nuclear proliferation and
the lingering scars of World War two no
sequence in the franchise captures this
better than Godzilla's first attack on
Tokyo in the original film after making
his startling debut in the film Godzilla
goes on a rampage through Tokyo one that
draws on imagery like the firebombing of
Tokyo and of course the bombing of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki the result is a
truly harrowing sequence that instantly
made the film a cult classic and one of
the most important pieces of post-war
Japanese cinema the series may have
become shallow spectacle later but it
started very with our picks these other
girls from WatchMojo oh I can replace
all 10 of them easily with moments from
the roland emmerich yeah and the last
two ones oh here in Kong Skull Island oh
that's some of the best Godzilla moments
in Kong's go Island zoo my own just like
advertising for Kong vs. Godzilla that
was fascinating yeah so our Godzilla
shin that greatly succeeded in the human
drama because it takes place in modern
day treats it as if this is Godzilla's
first time coming to Tokyo ever and it's
just scientists and people helpful
politicians all trying to work together
to figure out how can they possibly
defeat this evil monster it's great like
it's a great movie and it really bums me
out that American films can't get the
human drama - yeah there's much time as
they seem to want to spend on them it's
like the district nine of Godzilla
movies here like yes at least in the few
clips it seems kind of docu style but no
no it's not going through the history of
Godzilla it is fascinating to see the
trajectory and how this is one of the
longest-running is
the lawyers running running French I
think it's the longest-running franchise
of all time that's of consistency
because bond would have started in the
60s and this started in the 50s and then
the fact that they've crossed over to
having their own American adaptations
and even a cartoon oh there's a Netflix
movie yeah yeah well then countless
other kaiju movies that have grown since
then like the Gamera films yeah like
that I mean and and it's fascinating
even just across these clips to watch
Godzilla change in a weird way it
reminded me of like watching cars
changed throughout the years because you
know it's got the 50s version it's like
classic and cool then you get to like
the 70s the 80s and you're like I don't
know what's going on with Godzilla right
now you know and to see the suits change
and to see them implement CG sometimes
and the miniatures it's fascinating to
watch the kaiju genre grow over time one
thing I've really started thinking about
and they're really kind of shown out to
me through this video is that for a lot
of people especially growing up in Japan
back in the day like the kaiju and the
different monsters were kind of like
their superhero stories mm-hmm and I
think that's a really cool element of
this its glossed over impact this hack
is Godzilla was primarily a villain and
then he eventually became hero they have
a kind of flip-flop back and forth as
stated in this video as needed by
whatever script and honestly the outfits
and costumes can be very scary they can
be very effective same way with like
visual effects today it all depends on
the lighting especially when you know
he's like drop kicking and stuff they
look very cheesy but there are certain
ones that came from earlier years that
look great just because of the fact of
how you captured it is awesome monster
movies yeah honestly the whole fact
about Mothra spoilers for Godzilla king
of the monsters honestly if you haven't
seen it you're probably not going to at
this point
Mothra is talking about how Martha Rose
would sacrifice herself
I now understand why that choice was
made it actually made me appreciate that
nobody cause the liking of the watch was
more good yeah she gotta respect it now
well I was shocked to be like oh god
that monsters gonna sacrifice herself
for King Ghidorah like yeah and like a
Elseworlds version of the movie we just
saw yeah that's true I did not know at
all about that whole thing with how much
they hated
at Muroc one and they made the Zilla
versus Godzilla tea tasting out of like
30 seconds that's one of my really
that's a great expensive insult that man
is so yeah yeah that made me so happy
they've earned it cuz you know it's like
we're borrowing Godzilla when we made
that movie and so to express distaste in
a cinematic setting seems fitting well
they made a legacy they made this whole
legacy and then we [ __ ] all over it you
deserve all the crap I mean our Studios
involved a lot of people grief servers
yeah there's a lot of or there's a lot
more people involved than that then and
it just roland emmerich it was the late
90s we were we were experimenting a lot
of stuff in the late nineties I think
it's really cool to have the two
different styles more traditional
Japanese Godzilla versions that they're
still you know producing and then of
course we get our CGI versions of
Godzilla that can bring scale to life
differently I hesitate to say better
just because scene sometimes I can be
pulled out by knowing that it's not real
although like and Gareth Edwards
Godzilla those shots there he looks so
real that it's it's terrifying the one
thing that the Gareth Edwards movie
reminds you of is that if you shoot your
big CG creature from only human or
possible perspectives it sells it a lot
more than if you have like a CG camera
that's flying out and there are no
physics and you know there's no sense of
scale and I'm glad that they included
that one moment they basically got the
proper two moments from the 2014 film
when Godzilla first emerges and then
that big money shot at the end with the
Muto yeah and that's what Kong's colada
needs to have congress's gots all you
need to have them fighting each other
and then they get an ultimate enemy mega
Kong it just looks like a giant King
Kong he's like twice as big if it's
humans who are creating them why are
they designing it to look like god I
don't know I was like what is the
practical like are you trying to trick
yeah you look like me maybe I'll be calm
around you so that you can kill me I
don't know what the point of that is
other than we can so we should people
make fun of Godzilla having babies and
then roland emmerich one but hey
Godzilla's had a kid you got him last
kid he had
kid and although we don't know for sure
what gender Godzilla is it's been
changed and debated many a time or
ethnicity I know
I mean ostensibly Godzilla would be
Japanese but maybe I was Ecuadorian
could be you never know the oceans a big
place and oft connected some may be
Godzilla immigrated or emigrated this
was fun thanks Andrea for requesting
this buddy had a great time guys what's
your favorite god Zilla movie leave it
in the comment boxes below subscribe for
the real rejects click that notification
bell shout outs out once more to Andrew
Hayes who's recently telling me about
Chernobyl oh yeah and I figured that
this would be a perfect time to mention
this he's thinking of getting involved
in nuclear science and possibly
developing some kind of mom a mom a gum
bomb and no other Hong if they're long
oh that's one application of nuclear
testing I don't know anyone who makes
bombs so that's a pretty ambitious task
good luck man Vlad Chernobyl was able to
help inspire you to figure out ways to
make our world better make sure to test
it out in your hometown of New Jersey
first oh yeah that place needs some
nuclear treatment take care